let's start with the my pillow nazi
mike lindell so i
mean i tweeted this there is a video and
someone's trolling the [ __ ]
he's sitting at some sort of courtyard
or i don't know if this is some kind of
you know hotel where he
meets up with uh gals on craigslist or
something but
it really looks kind of suspicious but
he's set up on a courtyard
on a on an outdoor table and he's got
his camera and he
he doesn't have any pants on he's out in
the open
he's got a suit coat he doesn't have any
pants on he's pantsless
the [ __ ] doesn't have pain he
couldn't even put
a pair of pants just put blue jeans on i
know you own some
some [ __ ] grandpa blue jeans
you [ __ ] mustache mussolini what are
you doing sitting out front of everybody
without your goddamn pants on you
[ __ ] weirdo
is this guy still on crack is he still
on crack
is that what this is because it really
does seem like this guy's on crack
because he's all over the [ __ ] map
remember
remember august 13th next friday next
friday
uh the former guy the cheeto dust
mobster is going to
uh rise from the dead and ascend to the
presidency again somehow i don't know i
guess
uh last just a few days ago last week he
was saying that biden and harris are
going to resign
at the same exact time when you know he
comes out with all his information on
august 12th or august
i don't know september 89th who the
[ __ ] tell
with these people so the goal post is
coming up here so they got to figure out
a way to move it
so he's trying to figure out a way that
he can [ __ ] move this goal post
because it's going to come up there
ain't going to be [ __ ] that happens
and and and he's going to have to create
a new event
that's going to happen a new end of the
world type [ __ ]
[ __ ] nostradamus over there you think
for a guy
that [ __ ] manufactured pillows he
would take a [ __ ] nap every once in a
while
jesus [ __ ] christ this guy